kyle is with us in Kansas City hey Karl
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks taking my calls daily [ __ ]
speaking with you sir you too ma'am
what's up hey babe I'm coming two years
old man my wife and I are gonna have a
baby next month yeah yeah I'm real
excited there's some real fear there as
well so I just figured I'd be an 80 and
not to ask you how balanced working your
tail off I'll always be in your business
up and also being a present bad and a
good husband because I want to do all
three but I'm I'm just wanting to pick
the brain about it so you're a good man
so what do you do for a living I'm an
insurance broker sir I'm just my license
I'm trying to kind of get this
networking going and building up my
business yeah so two things come to mind
when people ask me how I've managed to
pull this off and I have a good marriage
and a and good kids and a successful
business and so forth and not lose any
one of them to the other one and which
means somewhat of a balance right so
yeah and you know Sharon I've been
married 37 years so how have we pulled
that off the first thing that comes to
mind is that balance is actually an
illusion its mythical horse crap
it doesn't actually occur you're not
gonna be balanced when you are at the
hospital and your child is being
delivered you are not gonna be worried
about work you're gonna be out of but
you're gonna be completely out of
balance you're gonna be completely
enthralled with this new life coming
into your hands it's gonna be the most
cool moment you've ever seen in your
life and it should be and you should be
out of balance you should concentrate on
that right yes sir yes sir and so
there's a period of time here that
you're gonna be really all about being a
dad and that's probably gonna maybe
you're not going to stick with your
workout regime or your bible-reading
regime
or you're not going to be quite up to
par at work because you're gonna be all
about baby and that's the way it should
be and then there's a time you're gonna
be all about work because you got some
work to do and then there's a time
you're training for a half marathon and
you're gonna be running and you're gonna
have some time on the road you know and
out there working out or whatever so my
point is is that ab and flow in seasons
and if you spend the next ten years a
hundred percent focused on your child to
the point that you do nothing else well
that would be completely out of balance
and ludicrous and really even be
wouldn't be that good for the kid for
that matter but and so you're not gonna
do it for ten years but for ten months
or ten days or what our three weeks or
whatever yeah you're gonna be out of
balance and then there's a period of
time you got some work to do and you're
not gonna see your kid as much for a
short period of time because you're
gonna be getting your dadgum job done
right then there's a period of time
you're gonna be working out and there's
a period of time you're gonna pour into
your marriage and and so there's you
know um and flow you got to touch all
the bases it's not like we're not gonna
go to work when we have a baby and it's
not like we're not gonna see our kids
more at work it's not a hundred percent
but you're gonna have weighting heavier
on different portions of your life in
different seasons for short periods of
time so try not to put yourself on some
kind of guilt trip in other words that
you oh I'm out of balance I'm out of
balance you're always out of balance
you're on you better be out of balance
the second thing is that I've learned to
do and it was really hard for me because
I'm a little bit a DD or a lot
undiagnosed but it's true
and so um the second thing is wherever
you are be there don't be such places at
once in your brain while you're at work
concentrate on work work while you're at
work when you're with it with the high
homo your hunter your child and wife
turn off the stupid television be
present with your kid sit in the floor
play games read that kind of stuff
wherever you are beaten up and put your
phone up don't take work calls right be
where you are you going
date with your wife turn the phone off
leave it in the car look in her eyes be
where you are that's hard for me I'm
just good for me to tell you to do it
cuz I gotta go home and do it tonight
right but but thank you very much that
those two things have helped me a lot
and those are the things that old guys
taught me as I was going along is you
know I think sometimes people get all
tripped out and they go well you know if
I miss one soccer game the kids probably
gonna be scarred for life and in
counseling no they play 7,000 soccer
games
so you're they're gonna be okay they're
not even sure you know I missed a lot of
them I didn't miss the important ones
and I coached my son's ice hockey team
and I was there for almost every one of
those games but I missed a couple of
those and oh well you know it didn't
miss any birthdays I wasn't on the road
during a birthday didn't miss any proms
went on the road during a prom make sure
we schedule around that but you're very
you know you pick your battles but this
idea that you're a bad dad if you're not
home at 5:30 every night and you know
doing all this stuff you know sometimes
you got work you know and that's that
that's being a good dad
so let the thing Evan flow be
comfortable with the tide going in the
tide going out some rhythm to your life
rather than the straight line idea of
balance and I Christie Wright does a
great job teaching business boutique a
lot of ladies ask about that when
they're running a business how to be a
mom and run a business the mom guilt
thing right and she talks through all
that and it's the same answer she gives
exactly so amen cool question and
congratulations ma'am proud of you very
fun stuff hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book smart money smart kids
how parents can teach their kids how to
be smart with money give you a baby gift
that's fun